[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 soy herminia fernández
comenzamos
la crisis migratoria el auge de los
nacionalismos y la pandemia del cob y 19
han vuelto a poner las fronteras en la
mira france24 ha preparada una serie de
documental sobre varios pasos
fronterizos hoy comenzamos con el primer
reportaje en la frontera entre irak y
arabia saudita todas naciones que
rompieron sus relaciones diplomáticas
tras la invasión de kuwait en 1990
actualmente arar en la provincia de
anbar rodeada al oeste por jordania y al
sur por arabia saudita es el único punto
de paso en los 800 kilómetros de
frontera entre ambos países unos 60
camiones van allí cada día pero no
cruzan la mercancía se intercambia y
luego los conductores siguen su camino
aunque sigue siendo imperfecta y a veces
frustrante la apertura de la frontera de
arar marca el inicio de una nueva era en
las relaciones entre irak y arabia
saudita
para las poblaciones transfronterizas es
sinónimo de nuevas esperanzas bagdad y
riad hablan ahora de abrir dos pasos más
luz el water bad junto a séverine bardón
y olivier varzim visitaron el paso
fronterizo de arar que está volviendo a
la vida en medio del desierto aquí la
historia
[Música]
en el corazón del desierto entre irak y
arabia saudita a los camiones esperan en
fila los hombres preparan sus
cargamentos para que la policía los
inspecciones muestran un producto para
comprobar las fechas de vencimiento abre
uno al azar generar el puesto fronterizo
recobra vida
aquí vamos hoy actualmente hay 29
camiones en el área de intercambio y 8
están listos para salir ok muchos llevan
varios días aquí y algunos ya llevan dos
o tres días acá tras la invasión de
kuwait por sadam husein en 1990
arabia saudita cerró su frontera y cortó
toda relación con irak sólo 30 años
después el 18 de noviembre de 2020 se
reabrió el puesto fronterizo de arar
es importante es que no haya expirado en
trenes dígale que descargue
descarga descarga actualmente es el
único punto de paso en los 800
kilómetros de frontera entre ambos
países unos 60 camiones llegan aquí
todos los días y el general iraquí ahmad
yuma a cargo del puesto fronterizo ya se
imagina un futuro prometedor
muchos camiones transportan materiales
de construcción de arabia saudita iraq y
las mercancías son cada vez más variados
la apertura de este puesto es aún
reciente pero ofrecerá muchas
oportunidades de trabajo a los iraquíes
de la región de al anbar y de roth
[Música]
combustible refrigerante neumáticos todo
está bien estamos listos para mañana
mohamed yassín es uno de esos iraquíes
cuya vida cambió desde el 18 de
noviembre de 2020 antes este conductor
de camión de la región de al anbar tenía
pocas opciones para sus mercancías que
era imposible ir a siria que era
demasiado peligrosa sólo por daniele
ofrecía algunas oportunidades
para mí la apertura del puesto
fronterizo de arar es la apertura de una
nueva puerta para ganarse la vida mejor
un viaje a dar me toma cinco o seis días
mientras que en el caso de jordania
puedo tardar un mes en total debido a
las regulaciones la reapertura no sólo
ha aumentado mis ingresos sino que
también me devolvió la vida familiar
ahora mohamed puede hacer más viajes y
pasar tiempo con sus hijos
como estas pequeñas agua tú también vas
a querer conducir más tarde porque donde
está yusef está durmiendo
[Música]
hoy prepara su viaje número 45 en un año
ahora lo seguí en la carretera y sabe lo
importante que es este destino para los
conductores de camión así que mohamed
ayuda a los que le rodean a beneficiarse
también
vamos a salir en cuatro camiones mis
tres sobrinos y yo para llevar botellas
de jugo y agua a la frontera al mar
a poco más de 600 km en arabia saudita
musa del danés y también disfruta de una
noche con su familia pero no todos sus
familiares podrán estar presentes esta
saudita que vive nadar pertenece a una
tribu que se extiende por varios países
de la región algunos de sus familiares y
amigos viven en irak
amigo buenos días cómo estás
estoy bien y tú mira estoy en un
supermercado y cada vez hay más
productos sauditas esto es audita
también
eso es genial bueno si abren para las
visitas espero que vengas rápido si dios
lo quiere pronto pronto por el momento
el puesto fronterizo de arar solo está
abierto al comercio a los civiles
todavía no se les permite cruzar así que
las celebraciones de la tribu de musaid
solo van sus miembros audi estás
esperando el día y quiero decir aquí es
puedan finalmente reencontrarse con
ellos
la espera es larga cuando la frontera
aún estaba abierta a los civiles nos
sentíamos muy cerca unos de otros era
muy fácil ir allá
las tradiciones la comida eran muy
parecidas incluso nos sentíamos como si
estuviéramos en el mismo país solo está
a una hora en auto después de todo
durante 30 años
todos estos intercambios fueron
interrumpidos con el cierre de la
frontera en 1990 desapareció toda una
forma de vida
mi última visita a irak fue en 1989 fui
a visitar a familiares y amigos allá
hice algo de turismo me quedé 10 días
y fui a muchas regiones en esta época
nuestra relación con irak era todavía
muy buena luego fue la guerra del golfo
y todo fue en declive cerraron la
frontera y nos prohibieron cruzar no he
vuelto desde entonces
la apertura comercial del puesto
fronterizo de arar da esperanzas a las
comunidades transfronterizas quizás un
día cercano musaed pueda reanudar sus
viajes
como hacen hoy mohamed y sus sobrinos en
el lado iraquí
cinco y media de la mañana y tienen que
recorrer casi 600 kilómetros para llegar
al puesto fronterizo de arar
era atraviesa toda la región de al anbar
lo que tranquiliza mohamed
las otras carreteras no son para
nosotros
no pasa nada
hay mucho comercio en basora en el
sureste pero no tenemos contactos allá
así que podríamos enfrentarnos a
irregularidades por así decirlo
esta nueva carretera no escapa a la
corrupción que azota a irak pero aquí
mohamed se siente menos vulnerable pues
conoce a las autoridades locales
espera que la apertura de la frontera
permita el desarrollo de su región
nos alegraría que nuestros vecinos
sauditas vinieran a invertir en irak
todo el desierto de al anbar está
totalmente abandonado hay mucho que
hacer de verdad si invierten aquí
podrían crear muchos empleos para los
habitantes de esta región
con el restablecimiento de las
relaciones entre arabia saudita e irak
se han multiplicado los proyectos
transfronterizos la modernización de las
carreteras el cultivo de un millón de
hectáreas en esta zona desértica pero
por el momento nada se ha materializado
y los márgenes de las carreteras
permanecen desesperadamente desiertos
paramos así porque aquí siempre está
completamente desierto hasta la frontera
no hay ningún restaurante ni
supermercado ni siquiera en el puesto
fronterizo ya lo verán
las inversiones llegar a cuentagotas la
inestabilidad política y de seguridad de
irak sigue preocupando a los sauditas y
la influencia de irán abrumadora en irak
les dejan poco margen de maniobra sin
embargo la apertura de la frontera ya
está teniendo efecto
en 2020 el comercio entre irak y arabia
saudita aumentó un 15% y en el lado
saudita musaed ve muchos cambios
aunque la gente
allá por todos lados hay muchas
renovaciones
estos trabajadores están ampliando la
carretera y construyendo un
estacionamiento
así es desde la apertura del puesto
fronterizo
muchos jóvenes de los pueblos vecinos
también han comprado camiones para
oficiar con irak
hay que entender que para nosotros los
sauditas el paso fronterizo de arar es
nuestra puerta de entrada a europa no
solo a irak
porque sabían cuando fue cerrado el
comercio se desplomó aquí así que la
apertura es muy muy importante para la
región
para arar y su región una de las menos
productivas de arabia saudita la
apertura de la frontera supone la
promesa de una reactivación económica
si vendemos la mano que hay de nuevo
por eso cuando mucha gente se reúne con
sus amigos en un café de la ciudad la
conversación oscila entre la nostalgia y
la fe en el futuro
antes todas nuestras casas serán
construidas con cemento irak y tenía
buena reputación y comíamos arroz irak y
es más grueso nos encantaba comer ese
queso muy espeso usábamos muchos
productos iraquíes sí creo que en cinco
años esta zona volverá a ser atractiva
lo que hará que vuelva a los
comerciantes y las grandes empresas al
menos eso es lo que podría ocurrir se
habrá en el puesto fronterizo por
completo para parte de la prosperidad
del país se espera que aumente la
demanda de terrenos aquí y que la zona
se desarrolle
mientras llegan esos días mejor es el
efecto más viable de la reapertura de la
frontera es el aumento del transporte de
mercancías por carretera
ya llegamos la entrada hasta allá
tenemos que hacer una primera parada
aquí para registrarnos
tras 10 horas de viaje y mohamed llega
por fin al puesto de arco
sí sí sí ya vuelvo
al parecer hay que pagar un nuevo
impuesto no es diez euros pero no
quieren que pague delante de las cámaras
y este es el puesto fronterizo todo fue
remodelado por el gobierno esa bendita
aquí
tardaron creo que cinco meses en
terminar la concentración
de este tesoro
y aquí es donde terminará su viaje en un
patio enrejado donde están estacionados
los camiones de ambos países a
mercancías e intercambiará allí y luego
los conductores seguirán su camino a día
de hoy los hombres siguen sin poder
pasar sólo la carga cruzar a la frontera
una restricción que no facilita la
logística
buenos días aburre cómo vas me gustaría
saber cuándo llegarán los camiones
sauditas lo sabes
[Música]
no sé parece que hay un problema con los
conductores del otro lado y son indios
no logro comunicarme con ellos van a
llegar más tarde de lo esperado eso es
seguro
vale nosotros estamos en la frontera
esperamos estaremos en contacto
mohamed tendrá que esperar varios días
en este terreno vacío y sin comodidades
algunos de los conductores llevan más de
una semana ahí y dejan salir su ira
[Música]
no hay nada en este patio y no han sido
capaces de organizarlo adecuadamente
honestamente es deplorable la zona ni
siquiera está pavimentada está sucia
no hay ni siquiera un baño para los
conductores nos cobran 200 dólares por
acceder a esta zona que hacen con ese
dinero
aunque todavía imperfecta y a veces
frustrante apertura del puesto
fronterizo de arar marca el inicio de
una nueva era en las relaciones entre
irak y arabia saudita
para las poblaciones transfronterizas es
sinónimo de nuevas esperanzas bagdad y
riad hablan ahora de abrir dos puestos
fronterizos más
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar estas las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]